Hello and welcome, this is the final video as part of our introduction to Smart Objects
course and I just want to touch on a couple of odds and sorts of future learning that
you might want to go into from here.
Now we have looked at coding all of the game-paper-havia into a singular script.
Now we don't have to do that, we can actually move over to a secondary state tree.
This we use quite a lot when it comes to Fortnite or Lego, but what this allows us to do is
shift the functionality between different state trees dependent on the object.
And finally a fantastic video, if you really want to get into this in more depth, is a
talk that was given at Unreal Fest a few years back and that is exploring the new state
trees for AI.
That was for Unreal Fest 2024.
But you can follow this QR code, should take you directly to it.
Well thank you for sticking with us through that quite long course.
Again this is just an introduction, there is lots more that you can do with Smart Objects
but hopefully this has given you something you can start out with.
Thank you.